jusqu'à sa fin naturelle.
Considérer la mort comme une partie
du tissu culturel et social de la vie
a une influence sur les décisions quotidiennes des gens
quant à leur santé et aux soins.
Le patriarche du clan maternel de mon mari,
Nenet Katcha,
approche désormais les 100 ans, pour autant qu'on puisse le dire.
Il y a des signes grandissants
de son départ proche pour rejoindre Puya.
On pleurera énormément sa mort.
Mais je sais que la famille de mon mari
se réjouit à l'avance du moment
où ils pourront montrer rituellement
ce que sa présence incroyable a signifié dans leur vie,
où ils pourront narrer rituellement
le récit de sa vie,
tisser les fils de son histoire
avec ceux de l'histoire de leur communauté.
Son histoire est leur histoire.
Ses chants funéraires leur chanteront une chanson sur eux-mêmes.
Et c'est une histoire sans commencement perceptible,
sans fin prévisible.
C'est une histoire qui continuera
bien après son corps.
On me demande si ça me fait peur ou si ça me dégoûte
de participer à une culture
où l'on rencontre les manifestations physiques de la mort
à chaque coin de rue.
Mais moi je vois quelque chose de profondément transformateur
dans le fait de vivre la mort comme un processus social
et pas seulement biologique.
En réalité, la relation entre les morts et les vivants
est bien l'objet d'une mise en scène dans le système de santé américain :
les décisions sur la prolongation du fil de la vie
sont prises selon nos liens émotionnels et sociaux
avec les personnes autour de nous,
pas seulement sur la capacité de la médecine à prolonger la vie.
Comme les Torajas, nous basons
nos décisions au sujet de la vie
sur les significations et les définitions
que nous attribuons à la mort.
Je ne dis pas que vous tous dans le public
devriez courir adopter les traditions
des Torajas.
Ça serait un peu difficile
de les transposer aux Etats-Unis.
Mais je pose la question : qu'a-t-on à gagner
à considérer la mort physique non seulement comme un processus biologique,
mais aussi comme un élément de toute l'histoire de l'humanité ?
Qu'est-ce que cela donnerait
de regarder l'enveloppe corporelle d'un défunt avec amour,
parce qu'elle fait intimement partie de ce que nous sommes tous ?
Si nous pouvions développer notre définition de la mort
pour y inclure la vie,
nous pourrions vivre la mort comme une partie de la vie,
et peut-être pourrions nous affronter la mort
avec autre chose que de la peur.
Une des réponses, peut-être,
aux défis que doit relever le système de santé américain,
particulièrement en ce qui concerne la fin de vie,
serait tout simplement de changer de point de vue,
et ce changement, en l’occurrence,
serait de regarder les relations humaines impliquées dans chaque décès.
Cela nous aiderait peut-être à reconnaître que notre façon
de restreindre notre discours sur la mort
à l'aspect médical ou biologique
reflète une habitude plus vaste, que nous partageons tous,
d'éviter la mort, d'avoir peur d'en parler.
Si nous pouvions concevoir et valoriser
une autre sorte de connaissances sur la vie,
y compris d'autres définitions de la mort,
nous aurions le potentiel pour changer notre discours
sur la fin de vie.
Cela pourrait modifier notre façon de mourir,
mais plus important encore,
cela pourrait transformer notre façon de vivre.
(Applaudissements)